>> Jesse: WITH EACH OF THESE
TRAGEDIES, THE NATIONAL
CONVERSATION ALWAYS RETURNS TO
GUNS, AND OUR LAWMAKERS REMAIN
POLARIZED OVER TAKING ACTION.
>> THIS HAPPENS NOWHERE ELSE
OTHER THAN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THIS EPIDEMIC OF MASS SLAUGHTER,
THIS SCORCH OF SCHOOL SHOOTING
AFTER SCHOOL SHOOTING, IT ONLY S
HERE.
NOT BECAUSE OF COINCIDENCE, NOT
BECAUSE OF BAD LUCK, BUT AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF OUR INACTION.
WE ARE RESPONSIBLE.
I’M NOT SAYING, DON’T FOCUS ON
THE GUN PART, BUT WE ALSO HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THE GUN PART.
FOR TO TALK ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE
REQUIRES YOU TO TALK ABOUT BOTH,
AND VIOLENCE PART IS THE ONE
THAT GOES WELL BEYOND THE EASY
GOVERNMENT SOLUTION.
>> Jesse: THE PRESIDENT ALSO
RESPONDING TO THE SHOOTING
TODAY.
>> WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH STATE AND LOCAL LEADERS TO
HELP SECURE OUR SCHOOLS AND
TACKLED THE DIFFICULT ISSUE OF
MENTAL HEALTH.
LATER THIS MONTH, I WILL BE
MEETING WITH THE NATIONS’
GOVERNORS AND ATTORNEY GENERAL’S
WHO ARE MAKING OUR SCHOOLS -- WE
ARE MAKING OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR
NATION SAVED SAVER WILL BE OUR
TOP PRIORITY.
IT IS NOT MAKING ANY ACTIONS
THAT WILL MAKE US FEEL LIKE WE
ARE MAKING A DIFFERENCE, WE MUST
ACTUALLY MAKE THAT DIFFERENCE.
>> Jesse: SO, JUAN, YOU WERE
MENTIONING AT THE COMMERCIAL
BREAK ABOUT THIS GUY’S MENTAL
PROFILE.
HE HAD JUST LOST BOTH OF HIS
PARENTS.
WHERE DO YOU SEE THAT FACTORING
IN?
>> IN OTHER WORDS, FOR A YOUNG
PERSON, THAT IS UNSETTLING, THAT
WOULD CHANGE THE SENSE OF YOUR
STABILITY IN THIS WORLD, WE KNOW
HE HAD ALSO BROKEN UP WITH A
GIRLFRIEND, WAS FIGHTING
WITH A GIRLFRIEND, FIGHTING
WITH THE GIRLFRIEND’S NEW
BOYFRIEND, THEN THERE IS ALL
THIS RUMOR ABOUT IF HE WAS
INVOLVED IN FRINGE OR ALT-RIGHT
OR WHITE SUPREMACIST GROUPS.
WHEN WE START TO THINK ABOUT
MENTAL HEALTH, I DON’T HAVE ANY
OBJECTION TO IT, BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT, FOR
EXAMPLE, UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA,
THERE WAS AN EFFORT TO SAY, IF
YOU ARE GETTING SOCIAL SECURITY
PAYMENTS, FOR EXAMPLE, BECAUSE
OF YOUR MENTAL HEALTH, YOU,
THEN, IT SHOULDN’T BE ELIGIBLE
TO PASS A BACKGROUND CHECK AND
OBTAIN A GUN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS SAID THAT IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
HE SAID THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
SO, TO ME, YOU HAVE GOT TO LOOK
AT WHERE WE, AS AMERICANS, CAN
AGREE.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS WE CAN
AGREE ON IS THAT PEOPLE HAVE
SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO GET A GUN,
KIDS THAT CAN’T BUY A BEER CAN’T
BUY A GUN, AND YOU CAN LOOK AT
THAT AND SAY, YOU HAVE A LOT OF
TROUBLE, SON, LET’S BACK OFF
THAT.
>> Jesse: BUT NOT BUYING A
BEER IS NOT A MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEM.
>> Juan: NO, I’M SAYING, HE IS
19.
SO HE CAN’T BUY A BEER.
>> Jesse: I UNDERSTAND, BUT IF
YOU GREW UP ON A FARM, A GUN IS
LIKE A CAR.
IT’S A TOOL.
ALSO, IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT
AGREEMENT, LET’S NOT FORGET THAT
ACLU AGREED WITH TRUMP ON THAT
DECISION.
I’M NOT SURE THAT WHATEVER TRUMP
DENIED WOULD HAVE STOPPED THAT
TODAY.
WHAT I’M TRYING TO GET AT IS
THAT -- WE HAVE TO STEP BACK AND
THINK ABOUT THIS RATIONALLY.
THERE IS NO KNEE-JERK SOLUTION
TO THIS.
WHEN SOMEBODY IS PLANNING
SOMETHING, THEY CAN PLAN FOR
EVERY PREVENTIVE MEASURE.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS WITH 9/11.
WE SAW THIS WHEN THE WORLD TRADE
CENTER WAS ATTACKED AND THERE
STILL WERE ABLE TO PULL IT OFF
AGAIN BECAUSE THEY PLANNED.
IT IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO
PREVENT --
>> Juan: IT YOU’VE GOT TO SAY,
WHY NOT TRY?
EVERYBODY KNOWS -- WE’RE NOT
GOING TO STOP.
>> Jesse: KIMBERLY, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT SOME OF THE
PREVENTATIVE MEASURES THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN TAKEN?
DO YOU SEE ANYTHING SPECIFIC?
>> Kimberly: IT IS TOUGH TO
SAY BECAUSE IT IS AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION.
IN TERMS OF WHO HE WAS
ASSOCIATING WITH, VERY CURIOUS
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF PREMEDITATION
AND DELIBERATION.
JUAN BROUGHT FORWARD SOME OF THE
PEOPLE THAT PEOPLE MIGHT BE
SYMPATHETIC TO, A YOUNG PERSON
THAT LOST BOTH OF THEIR PARENTS.
HAVING LOST BOTH OF MY PARENTS,
AND UNDERSTAND THE GRIEF YOU GO
THROUGH WITH THAT AS A YOUNG
CHILD, GOING FORWARD WITHOUT
THAT LOSS, WITH THAT LOSS OF
SUPPORT.
NEVERTHELESS, THAT DOESN’T
NEGATE THE ACTION AND PERHAPS
THE MOTIVE AND INTENTION, EVEN
PRIOR TO THAT, HAVING THAT
HISTORY OF CONDUCT, VIOLENT
TENDENCIES OR IDEATION IN TERMS
OF VIOLENCE.
WHO WAS HE ASSOCIATING WITH,
WHAT WERE THE KNOWN CHOICES.
>> Dana: HIS MOTHER HAD CALLED
THE POLICE ON HIM BEFORE.
>> Kimberly: THERE WAS SOME
PRE-EXISTING OBSESSION AND FOCUS
WITH THIS, THIS WAS SOMEONE THAT
OBVIOUSLY HAD BEEN ENGAGING OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME AND A HISTORY
OF SOCIOPATHIC TENDENCIES AND
BEHAVIOR AND A LACK OF
CONSIDERATION FOR ANY KIND OF
DIFFERENT ANIMALS OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT IN TORTUROUS BEHAVIOR,
THAT SORT OF THING, THAT IS A
PATTERN YOU LOOK AT TO SAY,
THAT’S EVIL.
>> Jesse: SHOULDN’T BE ABLE TO
ROAM AROUND IN BUY A GUN LIKE
THAT WHEN ALL OF THAT IS
PERCOLATING.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS THE
SHERIFF MENTIONED EARLIER TODAY,
THEY WANTED TO BE ABLE TO KNOW,
IF YOU GET A CALL FROM A PARENT,
THE SANDY HOOK MOTHER SHOOTER,
SHE CALLED, DID NOT DO.
HER CHILD IS EXHIBITING
BEHAVIORS THAT SHE IS INCAPABLE
OF DEALING WITH, TRYING TO GET
HELP, SHE SAYS SHE CAN’T GET
HELP.
WHAT WE FOUND OUT YESTERDAY, ON
THE SAME DAY, IN WASHINGTON
STATE, A GRANDMOTHER WHO WAS
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY FOR AN
18-YEAR-OLD, SHE IS CONCERNED.
SHE GOES INTO THE ROOM, SEES THE
JOURNAL, AND STARTS READING IT,
REALIZES, OH, MY GOSH, THIS KID
IS ABOUT TO START DOING
SOMETHING AWFUL.
SHE CALLS THE POLICE, THEY GO,
ABSOLUTELY, HE HAS THE WEAPON,
HE HAS THE PLAN, AND THEY ARREST
HIM.
THERE HAS TO BE SOME PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
I ALSO THINK -- THIS IS NOT
GOING TO BE POPULAR, BUT THEY’RE
NOT GOING TO GET RID OF THE GUN.